you what was this story about you and
keefer sutherland didn't you help him
out with something wasn't he in some
trouble he
was uh what was it he had hired some guy
that he thought was tough
you know what i mean because guys
hollywood like tough guys around them
but guys they can control they don't
like guys that
is like a security type thing yeah right
and so
and this guy ended up to be a total jerk
right
and then they couldn't get him off the
set because uh
uh i think keeper
promised him a sag card and said hey
what am i gonna get my sidecar that kind
of [ __ ] you know
when somebody says that you're supposed
to be quiet
about it you know and and uh and where
am i going to get my line you know
and
and so anyway they ended up escorting
him off the
escorting him off the uh set
and about two weeks later
uh i get a call on
on george got a call my friend george
perry got a call
and uh we're down venice beach
and and uh george yeah yeah
okay all right kiefer what's up hey you
know what danny's that blood
yeah he's right here he gives me the
phone word ben
stan i got a problem what's up
uh somebody threatened my my my family
and
like what and somebody threatened his
family so he said
zoom and he told me i said okay don't
worry about it i'll take care of you no
no no wait then
he got scared hey i'll take care of it
no but wait i
keep her you always take care of it or
not yeah okay all right all right
he was panicked right but but he didn't
know what take care of a man you know so
do you think you were going to get this
guy whacked yeah i think so even if he
didn't
i don't have to whack anybody but uh
this
this is a wacky union and so i i kind of
me and george just kind of like told
this guy hey
it's the last thing you want to do pal
you know
put a cherry bomb up your ass and light
it and
i think two days later his wife got
flowers and
i'm sorry and uh
i ran into keith this was 10 15 years
i ran into kiefer probably five years
ago
and uh hey kevin what's up
hey hey trail oh wait hey i've been
meaning to call you
how are you doing you know because
i've i've helped a lot of people in
hollywood because a lot of them
think like i'm some kind of thug or
something and and and they
they i'll help them they'll either love
me
and and you know
be friends that call up on thanksgiving
and
come on over like or be scared to death
of me
yeah and just stay away from me and i
understand
because if if you're trying to be a man
if you're a man
and you're hollywood's got you thinking
you're really tough
you know and uh and you have to ask for
help
and this guy squashes whatever
problem you had then all of a sudden
you're either going to
take it as i'm weaker than him
or he's my friend you know
it depends on where your mind is you
know so
well i guess you've got those yes men
around people that you were talking
about before it can make that ego very
fragile right it builds them up it
builds them up it makes them feel
invincible
yeah right right you know what i don't
got no yes man
my assistant is a guy named mario
castillo
that i met in san quentin when i was
doing bloody and blood out
he was a resident he won't say he was a
didn't make
i was a resident i was renting a room
and and if you look at him
if you look at the dictionary my two
best friends a guy named mario max
and if you look in the dictionary dude
cholo killer gangster it's got their
pictures
okay that's just and both of them
came up the same way i did and uh
you know it's like uh
we all have like the same respect for
each other
you know whether i work for you or not
you will respect me you know period and
and i do they respect me and i
uh it's funny the way god works i met
mario in 1991
and been my friend ever since
he was in quinton when he came out he
got clean and sobered
i lived with him in max for a while when
i went through a divorce then when i
bought a house he came to live with me
because
he got sick and lost his job and i said
well worked for me so
so uh became my assistant and
ended up saving my son's life thank you
very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
makes me very happy indeed peace